all right angel angel where did you grow
up where are you from
um
i am canadian american
i was born in canada and lived there for
five years
two provinces
ontario and saskatchewan
and then when i was five
we moved down to texas
that was the very first place i lived
when i moved to america with my family
and
we lived there for maybe three years
then we moved to
alabama
we lived there for like three years
and then
to louisiana for like three to five
years
then back to texas for like three to
five years
and then to north carolina for one year
before are you moving around so much
um
my parents
are ministers religious ministers and
they
go from place to place you ended up now
you're in detroit
yes yes i'm in detroit michigan i moved
here from north carolina that was the
last place i was in the south
moving north how would you describe your
childhood with your family
um
i'm
adopted
um
my parents adopted me in their 40s
and i have four older brothers
and um
[Music]
it was an okay childhood until i reached
the age of 11 then things went downhill
and never got better
can i ask what happened at 11
my virginity was stolen from me
um
um you see
i'm homeschooled i didn't go to regular
school so
i would stay home and do school instead
and while my parents both my parents
worked
and the caretaker that was watching me
decided one day he
was gonna do it and it happened and it
did not stop happening until i was about
13 or 14.
how old is he
let's see
um i'm 22 right now
and he is 29.
so at the time you were home
i was 11 to 13. 11 to 13.
so that's like a
seven year age difference
you never said anything to your family
uh i finally confessed at to my parents
at like 13 or 14 and that's how it
stopped did he get caught or anything
um
he got caught by
his own brother
and um
he also joined in
when i was 12 or 13.
his brother did
well
are they
did they get convicted of anything
no
no no no no
so
since
since your childhood at home with your
family
are you working now
yes yes i do i just have a cashier job
in the city at a restaurant right so you
so you
you have an unusual fetish
yeah
yeah
see this is something that's new to me i
didn't even realize this existed until i
until you wrote me well that
yeah can you explain what a little is
yes um
there's actually two different things
there's little and then there's an age
regressor there are two like
very similar
um a little is someone who
enjoys the lifestyle of cute things
meant for
meant for young children
and
they can dress certain ways
they enjoy coloring
cartoons
stuff like that
and an age regressor
is similar but
they actually go into the headspace and
mindset of a child like
for me
mine is
uh babyish and
around that area
and um
four
like um
i go into the headspace of
a child that young
and you'll do this how often i mean
throughout your day or just during
sexual interactions or um
no uh i'll do it like once every other
day and it doesn't have to be sexual
um
it can be like
uh coloring with crayons i like to color
princesses sometimes
or like i'll snack on animal crackers
and a juice box and watch cartoons
and uh yeah although um in the bdsm kink
community it's actually quite
controversial
because people will say
oh that's wrong it's sexualizing
um
someone in that headspace yes
though
it's very controversial like
it seems
at first glimpse
that it's it's just a supplement for a
replacement for a
uh broken childhood yeah well no ever a
replacement of
like say a man desires to be with a
young child but he knows that's going to
put him in prison for the rest of his
life so
he finds somebody who's willing to do
what you're doing or is into what you're
doing
yeah that will be a nice little some for
some it is like that yes
for me the reason
i
sexualize it sometimes
is because
i lost my innocence too young and
[Music]
it's a way for me to
regress back and
consensually give that innocence away
because i did not get that chance
yeah that makes perfect sense yeah
other people will say
in the kink community we'll say that
it's wrong but
it's therapeutic for me
yeah
it's comforting to to watch cartoons and
and eat animal crackers and uh drink
from a juice box
yeah yeah i also it's that kind of
pacifier yeah
so so you'll suck on a pacifier for how
long like throughout your day or just
when you're playing only when i regress
to like
only when i'm regressing and
uh like an hour at a time
never more than an hour at a time
usually although i've tried to sleep
with it in and it just falls out
and are there other things that you do
that are
mimicking uh the
like the
baby
um
[Music]
i don't do diapers that's a part of the
abdl's lifestyle which intermingles with
age regression
and um abdl stands for adult baby diaper
lover i'm not into that but i do like
the uh onesies and stuff like this is
actually kind of
um
almost a onesie right here but it's like
a bodysuit i found it in like a women's
clothing store
have you ever seen a therapist about any
of this or um
i waited five years
um
after the
i've never told a therapist about this
all this
but like i waited five years after the
abuse happened to talk about that
was that helpful at all
somewhat
a little bit
yeah
and does does having a sexual encounter
with somebody where you're acting as a
as a baby or a child young child
is that
helpful in any way or is it is it it's
um
[Music]
it's therapeutic and very satisfying
with a conventional vanilla whatever
relationship interaction work for you
um
i couldn't do vanilla all the time but
like i am actually polyamorous
so as long as i had like at least
one or two partners in the lifestyle i
could have
a vanilla partner on the side because
i'm also like a hopeless romantic
so i would it wouldn't be too bad being
with someone vanilla
but i couldn't to be vanilla all the
time
and so you'll you'll you have partners
that are
looking they're
adult males who are looking for a young
somebody playing your role as a baby um
i only have one partner right now uh i
call them daddy
and um
their role is to be
is to care for me when um
i'm in that headspace
and
during everyday interactions
they make sure
i'm taking care of myself
but
i'm not just a little age regressor i'm
also a submissive as well
so i am there submissive
and i'm sure
most of a lot of the audience watching
this video would say this is sick and
twisted
but what happened to you and you were a
young girl was sick and twisted and that
fur wraps got this
whole thing on
yeah
yeah
yeah i've met people
that are like all right send me their
address they're due for a beatdown
but like
i don't wish any ill will or harm
towards them i've forgiven them i've
forgiven myself
it's
over and done with
then they're both married to adult women
by now so
yeah
it's amazing how how often humans will
harm each other
yeah actually um when i was first
discovering bdsm
it was
terrifying
the things that i learned that
humans are capable of
oh the things i've seen
um
but i am not a part of the extreme
lifestyle well
the most extreme i do is like a thing
called cnc
consensual non-consent play and i also
do a thing called primal play
what is that
oh that's where
you enter a more like
two partners enter more like animalistic
headspaces
where
the dominant partner is playing
an animal that is hunting its prey
and the submissive partner is
fighting back not to get captured or is
running away or hiding
and
there can be interesting noises that
come with a play from that as well
and that will result in a
it will result in the dominant um
either pinning his prey or tying them up
and
doing whatever he wishes
he or she wishes yes sorry
in the
consensual non-consensual uh cnc
yeah that is a type of play in which you
will always need a safe word
to make sure
to end play to stop because that can be
particularly aggressive or
it can be or if uh someone is ends up
going through a traumatic episode they
will need to stop and um
and calm down and stuff like that
so rather than re-traumatizing you you
find these kind of interactions
more
therapeutic
not therapeutic just
sexually enjoyable
yeah
and
oh yeah
how do you go about finding
partners that are into this uh
for me it's two ways um
[Music]
fetlife is one
um
and i'm also on a thing called discord
that has millions
of people in bdsm all over the world
and
that's how i've made like
long-distance partners like i've had um
long distance ddlg relationships that
stands for daddy dawn little girl
is there a large community of males that
are looking for for this you think yes
and it's not just straight uh daddy and
little girl there's also daddies that
look for little boys or mommies that
look for little girls or mommies that
look for little boys stuff anything
it's not gender-based
it can be any gender with
being a caregiver and any gender being
the little
partner
yeah and you don't have children of your
own
no
no
are you hoping to one day
um
i really want to settle down in a few
years and have some yes
well how would you
how would you raise your children
differently than perhaps your parents
did or not that your parents did
anything wrong but
what happened to you is just a tragic
thing but
what would you what would you do to
protect your child
i teach them that
even if they think that
they're doing something wrong
if they think they feel unsafe
they still need to tell me
because one of the things that my
abusers told me is that
don't tell your parents you will get in
trouble
and so that's why i kept it a secret for
so many years
so that's definitely something
i will train and teach my kids out of
i'm very thirsty um
one second
i also use sippy cups like these
sometimes
this one is strictly for juice water and
pop but i also have one that i use
strictly for milk
because i as a little
and baby i like to drink milk
do you uh do you go out in public and do
this kind of behavior or is it mainly
just um
i never dress like
a little age regressor out in public
but like
in a candy store or in the toy section
of a store
i can revert to that headspace
and like impulse buy and be like
hyper excited
uh when i age regress or go into little
space my voice does change
it gets uh
higher pitched and definitely sounds a
lot more like a little girl
and your partner
is is probably someone who
enjoys this and looks for it rather than
you know
i assume he
would would prefer this over
if you were more vanilla
that's not their only kink because they
also like
um
they like slaves
as type
people and they also like
pets as well pet play
what have you learned about
men or society
from
being in this
lifestyle
um
society
in this community
people are willing to do
scary things
and
but
um
some people
to me i think people join the bdsm
community
either
one of three reasons
one they experienced
sexual abuse or abuse as a child
or they
[Music]
they viewed that as a child like with
domestic violence situations like the
parents
beat each other up or something
two
they've been in a vanilla vanilla type
relationship for a long time and are
like
hey this is getting boring i want to
spice things up
or three
the uh 18 and 19 year olds that are
coming into this community they just see
stuff on tick tock or on social media
and they're like oh hey i want to try
that oh i hate those types
you're a purist
um
[Music]
not quite
but
like
if you're going to be a submissive
you need to educate yourself on what
it's going to be like
on what your limits are what you're
willing to do what you're not willing to
do
the type of relationship you want
stuff like that
yeah communication is key
yes it's key in both a bdsm relationship
and in a polyamorous relationship if you
have one
yes
where do you see yourself and this
fetish going in the next five 10 20
years do you see it like
growing and becoming a little more
extreme or is it just no use where
you're at and you'll stay right there
i will never be a masochist or slave
type submissive i will always be
little age regressor
a pet
a prey
with the primal thing
and
a domestic service up that's the type
that does household chores and cleaning
and stuff like that
see myself living
i don't know yet it's uncertain i can
see myself living in
two different kinds of hairstyles one
with a man
and
maybe
one or two other sister submissives
and then or the other is i can see
myself living with um
three dominant partners
so being monogamous is not for you
not for me at all no
i feel like i have a lot of love to give
and i want to give it out
like and i want to experience different
types of personalities that people have
so what are your
preferences in a partner
a romantic partner
um romantic partner is different than
my sexual preferences romantically i am
what's known as panromantic
that means romantically i'm okay with
any gender on the planet
and um
but sexually i am
heterodemisexual
and um
so
that
means um
i don't do one night stands because i
have to build
in order to have a sexual relationship
i need to build up an emotional
and romantic connection with that person
with a
male
or mass-presenting non-binary or
basically if they physically have the
male parts
i need to develop um
a deep connection with them
but if they are female or whatever
i definitely feel
i
want to
have more of a romantic maybe slightly
sensual relationship
go on dates hold hands kissing is fine
without tongue
and
like right now i find myself
i really want a girlfriend
and mommy dom type
even though right now i have a daddy dom
they are gender fluid
but
physically mask
but i
really want a mommy dom someday
to like
snuggle with
bathe me
make my milk bottles
um
brush my hair
pick out cute outfits
all kinds of things with
and um
yeah
our brother's getting complicated
the world is getting complicated our
world is getting complicated
these all these new kinds of
relationships
i think it's just
evolving
because
there are
all types of relationships
there's girlfriends and boyfriends
there's
husbands and wives married partners
there's
masters and slaves dominance and
submissives
daddy mommies and littles
there's
um
just all types and you can find um
people in
my lifestyle like the little cgl
community
all over the world um
my first
daddy was
a long distance daddy they just
they cared for me
long distance
and it was a romantic and emotional and
sexual relationship
it was actually a 33 year old man in
sweden
and
it was great it only lasted maybe six
months but
yeah so they can be from anywhere
yeah technology makes it easy
yeah yeah there's a lot of discord
communities um
you will find millions
of people
in the bdsm community on discord in
different types of servers and that's my
thing i'm on both fetlife and discord i
love it i love
talking with
voice voice calling groups of people
from all over the world
or like texting them making new friends
from
all over the world in my community and
getting to know them
does your little lifestyle
you know affect other parts of your life
other than just the what happens in the
bedroom
um
[Music]
it's a whole lifestyle yes
um like when i get
another daddy or mommy they can make
rules for me like
take your meds
let me pick out your outfit
uh take a shower every day or
stuff like that
and
or they could have me do tasks like
say color me a picture or
stuff like that it can
it it will also have elements of a
typical dom sub relationship because i'm
not just a little so when i get into a
dynamic with another person it will
definitely be like that because the one
i have the partner i have right now
we don't have a contract
he has not
done a collaring ceremony or
collared me at all which is a very big
thing in the bdsm community
and he only has one rule for me right
now and that's it
do you feel like the sexual abuse
that
you experienced when you were like 11 or
12 is that has that been the biggest
event in your life that kind of has
directed your
um
no
um
[Music]
i
was born to
a 15 year old
and my parents adopted me when they were
in their 40s but um
she was actually a party girl so
she used to like to do drugs and alcohol
and
so while she was pregnant with me
she drank some and to this day i now
have fetal alcohol syndrome
and that affects a lot of my
cognitive abilities memory issues
emotional issues
and that affects me every day i
i don't drive
i don't know if i ever will but i have
cognitive issues and memory issues so
it's really a bad idea too
and
the united states government won't
recognize it as a disability because i
can work part-time but not full-time if
i were to try to work full-time
i would
make a lot of mistakes because of my
cognitive issues
and
it would not end well
but
canada is probably better in that in
that
they are
more advanced in their neuroscience and
stuff like that so if i was up there
i'd probably get better disability
benefits
and
[Music]
they say people with fetal alcohol
syndrome are likely to get addicted to
alcohol or addicted to things in general
i have been addicted to candy in the
past
are drugs a part of your life no not at
all i don't do weed i don't smoke don't
do tobacco i've never touched a hard
drug ever i only take prescription meds
but i do drink alcohol occasionally but
i'm not addicted
since most types of alcohol taste
absolutely disgusting to me i'll only
drink the sweet stuff and i'll only
drink like
twice a month if that
yeah
all right angel thank you so much for
sharing your story
very interesting lifestyle you
i am happy to explain my lifestyle and
my part in the community
cool
all right thank you very much
all right thank you
you